my first conan invitation to showcase
for conan
i could not come and showcase the live
show cases
because i did not want to break my
contract
with the university of superior
university of wisconsin at superior
performing in their cafeteria i'm like
guess these non-traditional students are
getting my conan showcase set tonight
um so so i appreciate you keeping up
with me
a lot of work goes into a short late
night stand-up set join me
jp buck as i spotlight the comedians who
came up with some of my favorite coin
sets
this is the setup please welcome the
very funny
mary mack
i'm trying to remember when you and i
first met like i feel like i
if i go back and feel like my mind was
erased at some point because i feel like
you've always been in my comedy world
like i can't remember a time when i
didn't know you as a comic somebody
recommended me
for andy kaufman uh andy kaufman awards
in um and that year was at the hbo
um comedy festival in vegas that year
the eddie kaufman awards were
established by andy's family
years ago and to try and recognize
people that maybe the mainstream was
ignoring
and what was great is the show that i
got to produce
was hosted we had co-hosts reggie watts
yeah
and kristen shaw hosted the show and i
remember so many people afterwards came
back
who were just telling me about how great
you were i remember the first comment
i ever saw of yours about me was she's
interesting
and
encourage me no further like i was like
that's the best comment i ever got all
anybody ever said was
they'll never get it you won't fit i'm
like that's strange they say people will
never
get it because i i've done shows in all
the states and
seems like we all have a pretty good
time
back then submissions were i had a lot
of submissions through
vhs tapes i think that's what my first
thing the first things you sent me i
think we're on vhs
after vhs it transitioned over to dvd
and that became a lot easier to keep
yeah so i have this is book three of
a library of dvd submissions i've got
actually look there's the first
person in this book it's the m book
starts with mary mac
and there are four and then there are
look
there are 12 now total
you can never throw those out because i
don't have copies i don't have copies
boy i'm surprised i didn't send you like
real the real or cassette tape
okay but thanks for keeping those so we
met 2007. you weren't on the show until
2016.
uh you sent me an email that apologized
for the eight years that you were busy
you know didn't hear you say the jokes
in the following set have been tried out
in 34 of the united states
canada and mexico and seem to hit in all
the places
i know i do my own scientific
experiments like i don't feel good about
a joke going on tv
i i feel like i need to try it in at
least 11 states like that's my minimum
states
i need to to know because it's a thing
because i grew up as a kid
in very sheltered area so even still
some of my words aren't the right words
that people in other states
understand so i have to
do all these like trial and error like i
keep little
logs but that's what comedy is it's just
this experiment
and then you know yeah it's
interesting
[Music]
you know how i warmed up to do it was we
went down
and we were doing nine shows at the clay
county fair
in spencer iowa which is the largest
county fair
i'm sorry sorry to break everybody um
but the largest county fair
in the country jp yeah
yep so i do three days and they do three
shows a day
and clean to farmers and the lion
trainer
from there's tigers next door to me all
the time i have to
always be more entertaining than tigers
otherwise nobody's gonna come
that's a lot of pressure so um
i did my conan set up top
every show for nine shows three shows a
day three
three days nine shows and for the first
five minutes of
every show i got complete silence
to that set and i was like
i think it's good because i was like i
think that if they don't like it
it's probably going to be good so
that was like my rationale that's the
good those are the real people
right so like if i do some jokes in a
room of just comics
and they like them i'm not going to do
those jokes on tv most likely
or even in a like at a corporate or a
venue
i'm like oh of all the comics like these
and i don't think it's okay
because you're not playing to the real
people you're just playing to the other
scientists
and and so i i got to get those real
people in there
oh i'm so excited to be here um i have
two
degrees in clarinet so that's why i do
comedy
clarinet never came in handy for
anything unless
maybe like you're driving and then you
hit a deer
and you don't have a crowbar in your
trunk to put it out of its misery
yep yeah last time i hit a deer uh i had
my clarinet with me
and i only got through like two songs
and he was
out i think that was a good
way to start it out just tell us a
little bit about you
and until um and then your humor is
there because it's
dry and yeah i was
i like i still that's one of the jokes i
still use
you have your own sort of way of talking
you have your you have
you know you've you've got an accent and
it's
i think i just tried to be as much me as
possible
and i just kind of
like after years of like
places saying can you can you work on
your o's
no so i mean just like after years of
rejection you just have to
accept yourself the farther along i got
in comedy
it was okay i felt it was really okay
just to be honest
about you know i talk a lot about that
alcoholism in my family
growing up poor
my own experiences with
therapies and stuff like that and and
all i can do is just be myself and
and luckily it's a little bit
entertaining at times i had a bad
critique one time
that said of some other show it's the
lady was like it's like she doesn't even
know what she's gonna say
next and i was like that's the whole
point
that's what i'm trying to go for
well she got it she just didn't realize
she got it
yeah she got it and hated it
a lot of people don't know i have jokes
because
they're just sentences you know and
sometimes if you said a sentence and
didn't really like
ham it up on that sentence people
wouldn't be aware that was a joke
like um a lot of people don't believe in
antidepressants but
for a while my mom has taken them and i
felt great like
if you say it like that sometimes people
just be like oh that's not very nice
but you know it's a comedy set they're
ready for comedy so
so they get it and i and i hammed it up
enough
and you're then
that was the worst applause break ever
on this show
tall tall drink of water over there huh
andy richter
you could tell conan loved the idea that
you were doing a little bit of like
pulling him closer and then hit you know
knocking him down with that
tall drink of water and he just goes
away just like yes yes and you're like a
handy richter
in a situation like that where people
were like is it okay to clap we don't
know if we should laugh or clapper
and so i'm like oh no that was weird i
gotta put everybody on the same page
again like i gotta restart it
so that people feel okay with whatever
their response is
so so then um i just i just acknowledge
anytime
and even when i'm doing a live show i'm
like oh man i hope something weird
happens so that
even when i'm even i know this was a
live show but when i'm doing my regular
club shows i'm like i hope something
weird happens so we all have something
to talk about
i've lost track of the applause breaks
by the way
[Music]
let me leave you on some uh parting
advice if i could uh
don't ever let people walk on you okay
uh i gotta
i got a new model i am not
the victim do you want to try it yeah
ready and i am not
i am the killer
the tag line is you got to think
positive or
yeah because you got to think positive i
didn't know how to put the tag line in
there because they
enjoyed the i'm the killer part
so i was like okay i guess i'm done yeah
sometimes i mean you make that those
audibles sometimes out there you're like
well
this is such a good reaction why go out
and go after
one more line that may have diminishing
returns yeah louie anderson told me one
time he ended
a set two jokes early because he knew
he could never follow those jokes would
never follow
the one that he did end on
great job
he's just very talented and a smart guy
and a gracious person
and i just needed him to know
that he does a great job and i wanted to
tell him
right there you're doing such a great
job and i needed to tell him because i
was like i might never get to talk to
him again he's got to know he's doing a
good job
that was really your moment there for
him to tell you and i love that
it's so huge to be like no no i want to
let you know
how much i appreciate you i'm amazed by
conan like i've
ever since the first time to do it i've
been bragging about him because
he's amazing like you don't see other
shows like
that where a the host is gracious to
start with and
kind and nice and then um
you he the show you see on tv is so
close
to the show that he does live like it
there's really not much change you know
i see
other people try to do television shows
and they're they
make the audience stay there for like
five hours
i mean like where it's like plus the
getting there and the
and like um he's so good i remember the
second time i did
did it i asked for a monologue sheet so
i could
see what's he going off of and i get the
monologue sheet
and there's just six sentences and then
i mean
like i don't know if um he does goes
and memorizes everything but it's a lot
of just riffing it feels like
which um and you have to nurture
everybody and make everybody
feel like they're in a safe space to
succeed and and
try and experiment and um
and also you have to have the talent
yourself to to warm up that show
and get it going to get that show going
and
um and the fact that he can do all of
that
and and um and still be able to laugh at
himself when it doesn't go right too
and it's just like it's a great it's
great so i needed
him to know that he was doing a great
job
[Music]
frank drebin says my new favorite
comedian exclamation point her quiet
humble delivery lets her bizarros sneak
twists sneak up on you like blam
i don't think this audience was tuned in
to her old subtlety
i was cracking up while those folks were
merely politely chuckling
oh that's really nice that's the whole
thing is if
you can say a lot of stuff if you say it
the right way
so so um you can say some pretty dark
things if you smile while you're doing
it
zero dark eagle or oh dark eagle
well she has funny jokes but really slow
deliveries she does have a good voice
for animation though
she already sounds like a cartoon
character yeah well that's been working
out for me
actually so i can't argue with that
slow delivery i thought i talked pretty
fast for that set
zingli i'm just gonna say i'm gonna
spell it x-i-i-n-g-l-i
says i just want her to be happy that is
so
nice and but also a little bit loaded
because i'm like
do they know i'm depressed how why did
they say that
but but i i'm i've been good i've been
real good in them
so so so that nice person i
i really appreciate that benediction
and i i'm like i hope that for other
people
as well you
sent a number of thank you letters to
like every person that you interacted
with on the show
which i was like people are coming up to
me going i gotta thank you later
for mary it's like that's such a sweet
thing to do like not
no one else has done that not that it's
expected it's
unexpected when you're you get to be a
part of a good thing and people welcome
you
and and i just think
it's a good thing to do and it's like
people forget that they are appreciated
and so if just me putting a
card in the mail i can get it to them to
say man that was awesome thank you so
much for your help
then they they know they're appreciated
and then they feel better about what
they're doing
and i think it's good i think it's
helpful to let people know that